- I like these shoes.
- [Jo Jo] Yeah.
They are three sizes too big but I wanted
them so I got them.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh, I've done that.
I've done that.
I literally got it, it
was a half size big,
but I was like whatever, they're so cute.
- [Jo Jo] It's fine, I'll grow into them.
(laughter)
- [Kelly] You probably
will, you're so tall
and only 16, that's awesome.
- Thank you.
It's a good thing.
- So why are bows your thing?
They were my thing too
because I was in dance
and all that growing up.
- [Jo Jo] For sure.
That's how, that's actually
how they started for me.
You know, when I was little my mom,
I mean I was two years old.
When I was born actually,
my mom just kinda stuck them in my hair.
And my joke is as I got older,
my bows just kept on getting bigger.
(laughter)
But as I realize that bows
are like a part of my life,
I realize that I wanted
them to mean something.
And so, what I came up
with is see-one-aters.
And so you're wearing a bow,
or you see someone wearing a bow,
that means that they are see-one-ater.
So say, you're, you know at school,
or you don't have anyone
to play with at recess,
to sit at lunch with.
- Yeah.
- [Jo Jo] If you see
someone wearing a Jo Jo bow,
you know that you can sit with them,
or you know that you can play with them.
Because that person--
- It's a safe place.
- That's a safe place, that
person will be nice to you.
(applause)
- That's so cool.
- That person will be kind do you.
Yeah.
I actually, if you two are up for it,
I might have a little
present for you guys.
- I am up for it.
(cheering)
- Jason.
- [Jo Jo] I brought you and a bright bow
with lots of rhinestones.
- I love that it's yellow
too cause sunflower
is my favorite flower.
- Well there you go.
- Oh my gosh, I'm so into it.
- [Jo Jo] And Jason.
- Wait, here we go, watch this.
- I had to bring you a denim bow.
- Denim is my favorite color.
(cheering)
- I love it.
- Oh yeah.
- [Kelly] That is so sweet.
- You got a little flip to do,
got the back showing the front.
Okay.
- My bad.
- There you go.
(cheering)
- [Kelly] That's.
I am just letting you know,
that's a real man that's
letting you touch his
cowboy hat.
- Is it?
- You can sit with me at lunch, it's fine.
- You can sit with me at lunch.
- Good.
- I love that though. It's so kind.
And it's such a good
thing because bullying
is such a huge thing.
- [Jo Jo] It is.
- [Kelly] Especially in
this social media crazy
society we're in.
And so that's kind that you started this.
Oh look at that.
- [Kelly] So how many bows?
- Okay, we're good.
How many bows do you have?
- In the Jo Jo bow collection,
there are over 12 thousand.
- [Kelly] What?
- [Jo Jo] Yes.
And.
(cheering)
Yeah, and that was,
that was when I was
packing for tour actually.
I see the one that I am wearing.
But in this last year, we
sold over 63 million bows.
- What?
(applause)
- [Jo Jo] It's crazy.
So it's like, it's so cool,
cause to me that means that
there are 63 million people
that are being nice to people.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- 63 million people that
are promising to be kind,
to be loving, to accept everyone,
and to be happy.
- [Kelly] Or you have one giant fan,
that just bought them all.
(laughter)
- Well, that' too.
- [Kelly] I'm just kidding.
- That too, that too, that too
- [Kelly] No, I love it.
I think it's such a positive thing,
and it's so good to spread kindness.
- [Jo Jo] Thank you.
- It's beautiful.
So do your daughters wear bows?
(applause)
Do they sport this?
- You know?
I think so.
Navy doesn't, she barely has any hair.
- [Kelly] Oh that was me.
Oh she sports that--
- [Jason] More of a headband.
- [Jo Jo] We got bows on headbands.
- Yeah?
Well, that's your girl there.
- Oh my gosh, I love it.
Look at that pink Adidas.
- I'll hook you up.
I know someone who can get bows.
- [Jason] Hook it up.
Absolutely.
- [Kelly] So what, you're on
a world tour right now, right?
- [Jo Jo] Yes.
- So with, what do fans
expect from your show,
when they come to see you?
- The most--
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Extravagant, most crazy full out concert
you will ever go to.
Like cause I put so much
effort into my show,
and there is so much going on.
You know, everyone my
age who's doing shows
is just singing with a microphone.
- Yeah.
- And I was like, you know what?
I wanna put on a full
production performance.
- [Kelly] Spectacular.
- It's unbelievable.
And we just did 89 cities
over the last six months.
- What?
(applause)
- [Jo Jo] Yeah.
- Wow.
- [Jo Jo] And then January
I'm going to Australia,
and we're doing seven
shows over in Australia.
- [Kelly] Have you ever been there?
It's beautiful.
I love it.
- I love it, I wanna move to Australia.
- I love it, it's like a giant Texas.
I love it.
(laughter)
- It's amazing.
I love Texas.
- [Jason] My wife wishes
she was Australian.
- Really?
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Yes, she talks with an
accent and everything.
- [Kelly] They're all hot.
Everybody from there is hot.
Male or female.
Pick a person.
- [Jo Jo] I did have a crush
on an Australian for a while.
- I see why.
- Now no woot woes.
- Anyway, everyone in my
audience is going home
with Jo Jo's bow club box.
(applause)